the jurogan experience
how did you guys wind up with beavers
and butthead there
um so i had
i was making these animated shorts in my
house
and uh
just mailing out vhs tapes of them and
uh
there was a show called liquid
television
well i had gotten
i'd gotten um i made three shorts before
beavis and budded was the fourth one i'd
made and the first three had gotten like
the first one i made was on the show on
comedy it was called the comedy channel
um
uh night after night with alan havey
i remember alan havey yeah and
so and then i'd gotten in some animation
festivals and so people were starting
there was a show called liquid
television
on mtv that um
was on sunday nights and uh
they would license animated shorts so
i got
i got like three or four of mine
on there it all happened very quickly
like i had
they were
gonna they they asked me to send my
first three and i said i have a new one
and it was beavis and butthead and um
and then it so it got on that show
and then there was a long weird cryptic
negotiation where they said they want to
buy it and i said what for and like
and then
i negotiated it was colossal pictures
liquid did liquid with liquid television
and then finally they said it's over oh
it was a long ugly thing and
then finally mtv came to me directly i
still didn't know what they were going
to do with it i thought those little
station ids or something and
i was elated i was like this is amazing
i'm just making these things in my house
outside of dallas and
it's going to be on mtv that's amazing
and then
i sold it
i
i sold the whole thing to him for
something like
eighteen thousand dollars
[Laughter]
the whole property everything yeah i
mean i retained something that you'd
never see any money from but
i was able to get it back later years
later but how did you do that just
because they needed me to do it and i
just you know but it was
yeah i sold it uh but this was after
months of negotiating and i'm like well
it takes me it would i was animating
everything by myself it would take me
like six to eight weeks to make two
minutes
and after two beavis and budded shorts i
was kind of out of ideas anyways i
thought like
okay i'll just this will be my
you know admission fee to show business
i'll just sell this off just to meet
people and and have them know about me
and
and i
you know after like i went to different
lawyers and there like there was a this
mob lawyer in dallas was just like don't
sign it
i said well
then i just don't do this like i mean i
don't regret it because i
i think they were ready to walk away um
it'd been
months you know like five or six months
which i guess in show business isn't
that long of a negotiation all the time
but
yeah then they and then they flew me up
there and then they started talking
about we're gonna do 65 episodes and uh
i was
saying okay am i going to be involved i
don't like i did and they said of course
it's your baby and you know um
but they didn't say any of that until
they already owned it
they didn't want to maybe it was part of
the you know the whole poli shore of it
all and those people that had gotten out
of there but
they did they did their lawyer
had all the
bad intentions of a good lawyer but she
wasn't all that great and didn't know
animation so there were some big
uh
holes in the contract that i was able to
exploit yeah exploit later
yeah she thought that i was going to be
doing the entire all the animation
myself so there was like a
per minute fee that was like
three seasons in
my i got mike still my manager michael
rotenberg was also a lawyer said hey
this thing says they owe you a ton of
money
so yeah we had
we were able to i was able to get it
back and now i
own it like 50 50 with them so okay that
was after the movie and they wanted a
sequel and all that stuff and so
this movie that you got coming out when
did this start
getting developed
um
let's see i had the idea for it a long
time ago it was really about
three years ago and then
um
right before the lockdown because it was
friday the 13th march 2020.
i had lunch with uh
the um
chris mccarthy and uh
kai's hill edgar the paramount plus guys
and
and just sealed the deal right then and
then made the entire movie with everyone
on zoom and evercast
so when you pitch a movie like a beavis
and butted movie are you pitching uh are
you just saying look i want to do a
bavis and butter movie are you saying
this is what happens with peterson
butthead like what's the process well
with this one with the sequel
they've been wanting a sequel for years
and i've pitched different usually when
did you make the first one first one
came out in 96.
so it was like a couple years was it
like so the show
the short first aired on in 92
the series started in march of 93 so the
show had been on a while before the
movie came out like three years they
wanted it sooner or later
oh wow
so it was off for a while